and I want to quickly if I can just talk
about strategic voting because that's
quite important
just let me start with you what role has
it played in these primaries it appears
as though the consolidation around Joe
Biden by various other candidates who
have dropped out by the Democratic Party
is is playing out by the voters
strategic decisions I mean you take a
state like Maine for example Maine's a
quirky state they were the state that
voted Ross Perot second only to Bill
Clinton in 92 we had an independent
governor for many years we have
Republican senators and Democratic House
of Representatives it can go all over it
gave an electoral vote to Trump in 2016
for example many of the same people who
had voted for Obama
just before Bloomberg was polling very
well in Maine leading up to this but
right now it is a head-to-head about 34
percent both for Biden and for Sanders
and Bloomberg is way down this is a
state where Bloomberg would normally do
well an independent businessman that
works for the voters of Maine but not
right here we're seeing the Democratic
primary voters saying to themselves
we need to consolidate and if I'm not
for Bernie as as as joe said they
already know whether they're a Bernie
Sanders voter or not if they're not
they're consolidating around around
Biden strategic voting yeah I think you
see a lot of Democrats who maybe had
other favorites particularly as those
favorites drop out now turning to Joe
Biden another place in addition to Maine
where that is really strong plan on is
in Minnesota
right though the polling that's come out
over the last week or so showed Joe by
very far back in the pack Amy Klobuchar
may be fighting it out with with Bernie
Sanders to win her home state but as
Klobuchar and others have dropped out
Joe Biden now looks to be in the lead in
Minnesota and may actually pull out a
win there after having been you in a
single-digit polling situation you know
less than a week ago and and so right
that's really the right that momentum is
the result of voters making choices that
he's maybe wasn't their first choice but
it is their choice now going forward in
the primary process before we go affair
let's quickly talk about Minnesota and
Massachusetts and again it goes back to
that strategic voting I mean as mention
previously Massachusetts is the state
where Warren is the senator
she was polling a strong second but
Bernie Sanders was actually polling
first and Biden was a third at third in
the polls but that is flipped Elizabeth
Warren is now coming in a distant third
and Biden is winning that state that was
not the projection ahead of these this
voting day that is showing even the
Massachusetts voters who have some of
the most reasons to care about Elizabeth
Warren that they are consolidating
around what they perceive as the
stronger person to take on Trump in the
general election in the fall so I think
it also shows the the rank the role of a
political party right it's an
organization for coordinating and so the
the officeholders the other candidates
having a you're essentially discussion
semi publicly amongst themselves over
the best path forward and then signaling
to the parties voters about what the the
solution they've come up with and the
solution to rally behind they're
reasonably popular you know reasonably
well regarded a former vice president as
the party's candidate as opposed to
senator Sanders who despite his his
virtues right has not been a member of
the party by his own choice right for
you know his whole political careers
refused to associate at that party and
so the party is an organization choosing
a candidate from among their own ranks
and the party in the electorate
following the leadership I think are the
sort of two important political science
stories of the night